marjorie taylor green she's done it
she has upended our political tradition
she is a unique
threat to our order and to our civil
discourse you know what she did
she did something no one else has ever
done she made
a clumsy nazi comparison tweets out
quote
vaccinated employees get a vaccination
logo just like the nazis forced
jewish people to wear a gold star
vaccine passports and mask
mandates create discrimination against
unvaxxed people
who trust their immune systems to a
virus that is 99 survivable
outrageous right they got a booter from
congress they've got we need to take a
stand
she made us a sort of clumsy simile
mccarthy kevin mccarthy's the republican
leader in the house
he tweets out marjorie is wrong her
intentional decision to compare the
horrors of the holocaust
with wearing masks is appalling let me
be clear
the house republican conference condemns
this language that's good finally
now now the libs will like us now good
we're going to score points they're
probably going to give us credit for
that too right because we all agree not
not crazy marge retailer green
but we the respectable republicans and
the democrats
we all agree that it is never acceptable
it's so
out of character for our politicians to
make nazi comparisons right
right is that true i don't like nazi
comparisons
because i think they're lazy i usually
it's usually because people don't know
anything about history so they just
every single thing that ever happens
they compare to the one thing in history
they sort of know a little bit about
which is the second world war so they'll
say you know trump drank water you know
who else drank water hitler did that so
so i think they're lazy i think they're
imprecise but
why do we need to rush to disavow
this sort of stuff why do we need to say
anything at all
marjorie taylor green sent out a tweet
using a very common
uh uh not my favorite but very common
rhetorical device
why do why do we need to rush and say
it's bad it's horrible she's terrible oh
no
i'm sorry i who cares
who cares she is
a not a particularly influential
member of congress i think she's a
freshman congressman isn't she it's not
like she's been there for 30 years
she doesn't lead committees who cares
i googled i googled trump nazi
just to see if really marge retailer
she's the only politician ever to make
one of these comparisons
just just the first page i looked just
at the first page just
open open open i didn't even open all of
them here you go here's the stack here's
a stack of
washington post trump's refusal to
acknowledge defeat mirrors the lie that
fueled the nazi rise there's one
uh trump obviously admired hitler
says anne frank's stepsister referring
to claims that he he studied his
speeches
okay unsubstantiated claims by the way i
think there's business insider
we've got uh cnn's christian amanpour
contr compares trumpism
to nazi pogrom okay there's one that's
from cnn right
the austin american statesman trump
takes tactics
from hitler's playbook okay there's that
one oh here we go from the guardian
spike lee compares donald trump to
hitler that's another one here we go
wbur
this is actually hosted by harvard
so you can you can find this on on
harvard's website one scholar on
similarities
and substantial differences between
trump and hitler there you go there's
one
we've got the dallas news joe biden
likens ted cruz to nazi propagandist
goebbels for helping trump spread big
lie about election fraud oh there we go
there's two two nazi references in there
that's from dallas news the sitting
president by the way did that
uh opinion here in the inquirer is it
wrong to compare trump to hitler no
and not just democrats by the way some
republicans too
here's sky news us capital riots arnold
schwarzenegger compares pro-trump riders
to nazis
who attacked jews during night of broken
glass
oh boy that's like the first 10 search
results when you google you i could we
could be here
for months but all that totally fine
where is kevin mccarthy going to disavow
arnold schwarzenegger
are the democrats gonna disavow joe
biden
and all the others and christian
amanpour are they gonna now
we're never gonna talk to cnn no more
not no
no because this is so contrived actually
right now if you if you had two polls of
the republican party in the house
there's marjorie taylor greene right who
says some kooky things no one doubts it
says some clumsy things no one doubts it
but you got her on one side
you have liz cheney oh respectable liz
cheney
she's the conscience of the republican
party she can you believe
those republicans kicked her out of her
leadership position so awful
she's a good kind of republican okay
look hey look
i'm a democrat you know you hear this
all the time i'm a democrat okay i
hated bush i disagreed with bush but
he they were respectable republicans
back with bush and cheney
not like trump so liz cheney let's say
liz cheney would never oh no she did she
made a nazi comparison like
three weeks ago quote the 2020
presidential election was not stolen
anyone who claims it was is spreading
the big law
turning their back on the rule of law
and poisoning our democratic system
what's funny about this one it so the
the big lie is a phrase coined by hitler
in mein kampf
but what's funny is that the supposedly
sophisticated intellectual
serious republican liz cheney is using
and and all the democrats by the way
are using that phrase in the wrong way
when when hitler coined the phrase the
big lie
he was accusing jews of spreading a big
lie about germany's defeat
in world war one so when if you use the
analogy
in the way that liz cheney and the
democrats are here they are actually
putting themselves in the position of
the nazis
the only difference i see here is that
at least marjory taylor green's clumsy
nazi comparison
was coherent liz cheney's which she sent
out just three weeks ago
not even was not coherent
but we need to disavow her disavow her
every everybody is making these
comparisons i think except for me
i think i might be the only person who
does not make nazi comparisons in public
life
how many all this the sophisticated
republicans do it
the you know the really the special you
know elite republicans do it
the the base republicans do it the
the every you know faction thereof the
democrats do it
so why is it a big was it only a big
deal when marjorie taylor greene does it
because the left is pushing the agenda
and they don't like her
and they don't like her raising any
questions about
about their various programs and they
know that she's an
easy target because she says kooky
things the left is pushing the agenda
with the help of squishes
you know what what's the what is the
worst most horrible event in the history
of the united states
uh maybe you would say september 11th
yeah that's a good good option maybe you
may pearl harbor
you might say i don't know the civil war
i was pretty bad huh
no no what what the libs would like you
to believe
is that at least tied for that
title with with those events if not even
superseding it
the capital insurrection
of january 6th do you don't need to
don't take the libs word for it
even respectable former republicans
like george will say the same thing you
have something new in american history
that is a political party defined by the
terror it feels for his own voters
that's the republican party right now
every elected official is frightened of
his voters therefore doesn't respect his
voters doesn't like his voters
and is afraid that a vote for this will
be seen as an insult to the 45th
president
there's no reason i mean mcconnell has a
point they're going to be lots of
investigations
journalists are going to go through this
there are 450 some
criminal charges now being brought with
a hundred more probably to come so
there's going to be
lots of information about this i would
like to see
january 6th is burned into the american
mind as firmly as 9 11
because it was that scale of shock to
the system
and i think there will be a commission
but it is controversial for that reason
he would like to see one six
burned as firmly into the american mind
as 9 11.
because it was the same sort of shock to
the system
george will believes that january 6 is
among the worst
things to happen in american history
don't think that's true i don't think it
was i think it was
bad i don't like it
i didn't participate in it
but i don't think that the horn guide
dancing around the desks
and the smiley guy stealing pelosi's
lectern
i don't think they're among the worst
things ever to happen in american
history
i don't think it was the worst thing to
happen that year
that year right the year leading up to
january 6th
you had
you had leftists burned down the country
mult city after city after city civilian
buildings
government buildings killing innocent
people burning down businesses
where's the commission where's george
will's outrage
the republican elected officials they
disrespect their voters they don't
they're afraid they hate their voters i
think george will is projecting here
i think he has no respect for the
republican voters
but very often i think the republican
base voters
have a little better handle on things
than do
the genius elite expert participants in
the liberal establishment
just getting back to that example at the
top just look at the
wuhan institute of virology the
republican base knew from the very
beginning
that that wuhan institute of virology i
was a little coincidental how close that
was to where the virus was discovered
but all the genius elites in both
parties said no it's crazy that's crazy
ridiculous you're so ignorant stop
oh man that was close ring the bell
subscribe like so that you will get
notifications and
beyond that sure it's good to get the
notifications on youtube but you got to
head on over to apple podcasts
google play spotify myspace live journal
i don't know
all those podcast apps where you can get
the audio version
there have been some shenanigans
recently with the big tech companies
head on over there subscribe please
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you